what's happening reject nation happy
monday to you we're gonna watch today
from cosmic wonder first spider-man 3
video shared by
tom holland gwen stacy in spider-man 3.
i hope it's an emma stone rumor just to
make things
more confusing oh yeah by the way uh
warren i were talking this morning
figuring out a time to do some type of
like vid another video collab perhaps
sometime next week so
keep a lookout for whatever that is this
holiday season
how's it going everybody it's lauren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and today
things are getting so exciting tom
holland has
finally shared his first official video
directly from himself for
spider-man 3. we knew that production
for spider-man 3 had started but
now tom holland is on the set we already
knew that the production crew was on set
the builders of the set were of course
there working on it tom holland's stunt
devil was even sharing videos of him
performing stunts as well for spider-man
3 but now we finally have confirmation
that tom holland is indeed
in atlanta and he shared a video with us
exclaiming how excited he is
and we're going to dive right into this
video but first a big congratulations to
youtube
user dark cable 59 hoppy congratulations
irons i need to figure out exactly how
you do these giveaways
in my description and we'll get you your
prize win one and find out this week
with another spider-man funko since
things are getting so exciting this week
is going to be the
imposter i'm going to set up so many
different fake accounts
just to try to get one of your phone
calls not only do we have this video
today but we also have some news about
spider-man
i just need to follow him on instagram
okay so we just landed in atlanta
and uh his song is not in mind three
let's
go so short but sweet but also
officially confirming that adorable
atlanta at marvel studios and filming is
starting
and of course you know what that means i
thought he was filming uncharted i don't
know what's happening
leaks we get leaked photos sometimes
in fact i'm surprised tom holland didn't
just spoil the actual title of the movie
right then and there in that video let's
go our boys growing up
i'm so proud let's go oh while till the
movie comes out there's plenty of time
for him to spoil things and we do have a
confirmation from
a sony executive that we are getting our
first look at spider-man 3 before the
end of the year so a teaser for
spider-man 3
incoming in just a couple of months so
filming for spider-man 3 is about to
happen tom holland
is on set and we also have another big
report today as i mentioned about
spider-gwen and this is coming from
daniel
richmond daniel has already released
some scoops about spider-man 3. and
today according to his patreon account
he says that he has heard emma stone
might return for the spider verse type
of movie that is going to happen in
spider-man 3.
and they are planning on having her in
spider-man 3 as
spider-gwen now spoiler that would be
cool
that would be really cool now of course
for those of us who have seen it we know
that she
dies at the end i would be amazing kind
of be in love with that
exactly are you going to go into these
other different universes to get these
different characters
now of course we are dealing with ah
abby pretty cool
because she does indeed die in that
universe but that does not mean
that there's not another alternate
universe in which she has fully embraced
and become
spider gwen andrew garfield may not be
spiders still looks like
she is spider gwen and this could be the
spider gwen that we see
in spider-man 3. now we have so many
characters rumored to be in this movie
at this point in time there's another
rumor that kirsten dunst could be
reprising her role as mj and there's
another rumor that we could even be
getting harry osborne from the amazing
spider-man universe as well
and with so many characters being
rumored you have to wonder how exactly
they're going to fit them all into the
movie
well i have a theory because spider-man
3 still does need to be about
r peter parker it doesn't need to be
about 20 different characters
yes seeing all these characters would be
epic the spider-verse being set up is
definitely going to be something that
everybody has been wanting for such a
long time
but i do think it's going to be just
that i think it's going to be a
setup for the spider verse i think that
doctor strange is going to show our
peter parker
i'm okay with you okay with different
universes
while mentoring peter parker because we
know that doctor strange
is going to be peter's new mentor type
figure and we know that spider-man is
going to be in a
lot of trouble so perhaps doctor strange
shows peter parker different spider-man
universes to show him that it's not just
him but in almost every other alternate
universe
spider-man and other versions of
spider-man have their hands full
it's not an easy job to be spider-man
it's not something that you can just do
and everything is okay all the time sure
i think that we're probably going to see
something very similar to this and then
by the end of the movie the actual
real-life spider-verse is going to be
established i think we'll definitely get
cameos from toby mcguire andrew garfield
and some other characters as well from
their
universes but then we will get at the
end of the movie a setup for
new spider-man entirely a new miles
morales a new spider-gwen and possibly
jessica drew as well
we do know that olivia wilde is going to
be directing a spider-woman type of film
rumored to be in the mcu in some way
shape or form so i think there's no
doubt that the spider-verse is coming
it's going to be set up in spider-man 3
however i do think that the multiverse
is going to play a little bit more of a
minor role in spider-man 3 and still
focus on
r peter parker which of course it is his
movie and is what he deserves
but be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest
spider-verse news i'll update you if i
hear anything
again super exciting tom holland has
shared his first video about spider-man
3 which means we are going to be getting
more
very very soon so let me know how
excited you are about spider-man 3 in
the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching weirdest spider-man journey in
history
of course tom holland is excited to be
back on set film i was a little bit
confused because when that set photo
came out of him
at an unheard of yeah i thought that
meant they were filming that right now
but i guess they filmed it and unless he
was having some
weird ass schedule of phil going back
and forth between
uncharted and as much i don't imagine is
the case his enthusiasm for it
automatically just makes you go yeah i
can't wait
just like it seems like he's just so
excited just to be filming again for
this especially because it's been such a
weird journey i mean remember that time
when it was they had to do videos of
yeah i know spider-man not being with
marvel's a sad thing sony's got good
plans and it got back into the mcu
so it's been a long journey especially i
can imagine on his
end of wanting to get back into
swinging into action for spider-man mcu
uh spider-man 3 whatever the hell the
title is going to be called i know he
did some video about him holding the
script but it doesn't reveal the title
i saw that video but i didn't see this
one what excites me that from the
information that we got in this video in
particular
is actually the possibility of emma
stone returning a spider gwen
i think that's a really cool way to
bring her back
you know like when i read this title of
gwen stacy returning i was like what is
what wha why why would emma stone that
she died
we can she died this is a live action
spider noir as well can nicholas
i thought they were like going to segway
into like amazing spider-man 2 and redo
that ending or something if they
actually get emma stone to reprise her
role as gwen stacy
in in spider-gwen just think about that
imagine you're just swinging onto the
screen and she's in a spider-gwen outfit
how exciting would that be her and
andrew garfield
were one of the best parts of those
pretty lackluster
spider-man movies right yeah and i think
even more than
andrew garfield to some extent i feel
like emma stone is a little bit more
praised
than andrew garfield is in some ways if
you don't even get andrew garfield to
make a cameo as spider-man
i think that would be kind of a cool way
to put a final stamp on
uh the amazing spider-man films that
didn't get to have a part three to cap
it all off
yeah yeah well this just got my mind
running too hearing the different
details about like maybe doctor strange
then would swoop in and kind of take
peter on a mentorship journey that
involves like removing him from his
current timeline where
[ __ ] is hitting the fan it made me
wonder yeah about all the possibilities
because then i'm like well how is gwen
stacy still alive is it the same gwen
stacy from that timeline because
at least if there are several spider-men
and they all look different then it
seems a little odd that the two gwen's
would look exactly the same
i could totally see a portal opening up
right before her spine is about to hit
the ground and then you know
her dropping through it in some kind of
other circumstance popping up so yeah i
mean just like tom holland's
innate enthusiasm at the top of this got
me super excited and then yeah the
possibility of just seeing like
all these different spider-verse
characters that have popped up in the
live-action movies over time that have
helped pave
the way for this mcu rush of films how
paved the way for this multiverse as
much as it's starting to feel like dang
everyone's gonna be in this movie i
don't know how it's gonna work at the
same time i do like that community of
like yeah let's take the parts of this
franchise that we're good
and that we're working and let's give
them a second life here
you know i think it's really cool i
think that them using like some cameos
here or there but keeping it pretty
centrally focused on whatever adventure
tom holland's peter parker has going on
sounds neat this is one of those cases
where i
really want some set photo leaks
i want to zoom in way too fast
i want the set photos but i love the
idea more of them putting a capper for
the trilogy of the tom holland films you
know like the infinity war end game
in between but also letting it be
ultimately a setup for an
actual spider-verse live-action film
that sounds
great i wouldn't want this to be the
spider-verse film
but i don't mind it being something
that's like teasing don't have a proper
setup for one
anyway guys what'd you think of this
news does tom holland's enthusiasm
feel as contagious to you as it does to
us leave your thoughts down below
do you want emma stone to appear
subscribe click that notification bell
catch you guys soon and check and
subscribe to warren's channel too
yeah do that that's important
[Music]
you